ja wir sehen leider gottes immer wieder
dass sich gewisse dinge wiederholen dass
menschen die eben seit jahren in
deutschland sind und nicht in den
arbeitsprozess integriert sind ja
irgendwann auffällig werden sich solche
auffälligkeiten häufen und am ende
leider gottes dann teilweise bluttaten
geschehen also wir müssen hier wohl
genauer hinsehen so und sobald menschen
auffällig werden mit gewalt halten
sobald sie irgendwo psychologische
gutachten benötigen und so weiter dass
wir hier wirklich schauen und überlegen
ob wir solche leute nicht auch
losbekommen stichwort subsidiärer schutz
dieser begriff wurde ja quasi eingeführt
als so viele flüchtlinge damals nach
2015 gekommen sind für die aber das
individuelle recht auf asyl nicht
anwendbar war dann sagte man eben ja wir
können die aber nicht mit dem schicken
sie kommen aus krisenregionen aus
kriegsgebieten so weit so gut aber wir
müssen seitens der bundesregierung auch
mehr tun also appel und die
bundesregierung dieses thema subsidiärer
schutz noch genauer beleuchten ob wir
hier wirklich wehrlos sind oder sagen
müssten wir machen gezielt der
rückführungsabkommen und schauen dass
wir menschen auch in solche länder
wieder gezielter zurückbekommen wenn sie
bei uns auffällig werden
die bundesregierung müsste also ständig
wie darüber gehen müsste diese länder
beleuchten wo diese menschen herkommen
mit subsidiären schutz und müsste zu den
regierungen dort sagen liebe leute
können wir nicht einigungen finden
ihr müsst menschenrechte natürlich
einhalten wir helfen euch wirtschaftlich
und so weiter damit wir wenigstens
kriminelle menschen zurückbringen und
nicht unseren leuten immer sagen müssen
ja die haben subsidiären schutz damit
müssen wir leben
das ist kein weg entweder einweisung in
die psychiatrie oder eben frei
herumlaufen lassen oder abschieben ich
glaube wir müssen versuchen wirklich
schwere fälle wieder in die
herkunftsländer zurück zu bekommen